welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is bonus day four
and we're going to learn from the fourth
richest person on the planet at the time
of this recording with a net worth of
126.8
billion dollars mr bill gates
i think you know you can over
worship and mythologize the idea of
working extremely hard
for my particular makeup i mean
it really is true that i didn't believe
in weekends i didn't believe in
vacations i mean
you know i knew everybody's license
plate so i could tell you over the last
month when their car had come and gone
from
the parking lot so i don't recommend it
eh
i don't think most people would enjoy it
uh once i got into my 30s i could hardly
even imagine how i had done that uh
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and i loved weekends and
uh you know my girlfriend liked
vacations and that turned out to be
kind of a neat thing uh
now i take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so
disgusted with my uh current uh
uh itself you know i i was sure i would
never do anything but riding coach you
know now i have a plane so it's
it's very much counter revelations have
taken place
at high speed but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty
maniacal about the company and how far
that goes you
should have a mutual understanding so
you're not one person expecting one
thing another person to expect another
thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know
health or relatives or things that are
distracted but yes i
have a fairly hardcore view that there
should be a very large
uh sacrifice made during those
those early years today people come to
you all the time for money
i assume everywhere you go people say by
the way i have this thing you should
invest in but i have a couple of myself
i'll mention later no no
no a couple of things you should invest
in or things you should give money to so
how do you resist you have some person
who says no for you
or how do you do that let many people uh
many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health
we're super interested and you know we
have staff of 1500 people
and if it's to do with global health
some of those people come out and talk
through with you whatever your
innovation is and how we can partner
with you on that
you know so that's clearly in our area
if it is something that can
substantially improve k-12 education
then we're
going to be very interested in it if
people are asking outside of those
things
then you know fortunately you can say no
because focus is
is key to philanthropy the digital
revolution
internet social media all of that in
certain respects
it's made it easier for us to see what's
going on
medical researchers are publishing
articles every day
and all over the world people can
immediately see what the new thinking is
there
tracking the disease statistics i click
on the
john hopkins website every morning and
see okay which countries are
having a tough time with cases or or
deaths thank god for the internet
work at home you know our ability to
connect up with each other is driven by
that but it also
has meant that a lot of very
surprisingly
interesting conspiracy theories that are
false
sadly they spread a lot faster than the
truth you know so the idea that
did somebody intentionally cause this
thing completely false
even in some cases accusing me of having
some connection
that can be dangerous because it means
you know your willingness to believe
is the vaccine something i should take
should i wear masks you know if you go
for these simple but wrong theories
getting people to work together and
protect each other so we can get out of
this
as soon as possible that's really at
risk you raise the question of
how should the government deal with that
it's very difficult
ideally citizens are just well informed
and they know which publications are
very careful about what they say and we
don't have to
engage in censorship but so much of the
almost crazy false information is out
there that
looking at the companies like facebook
and saying okay what is their role in
that you know when somebody says
masks don't work which is wrong or they
say just take
hydroxychloroquine and you'll be totally
safe what is their responsibility for
catching
those things particularly when they get
out to large numbers that is being
debated
and you know i think we'll come out of
this with those companies feeling a
stronger sense of responsibility and
actually understanding
having the public debate about uh how
they need to help here
you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
a lot of people are going to get out
there and use it and that they're going
to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea
that you have well each of these
businesses
is an entrepreneurial business uh the
overreaching theme is that yes
i believe in the internet i believe
it'll get increasingly popular
and we're doing some neat new things to
take advantage of that
is you've got a lot of cash on hand yes
right all right it puts you in an
envelope position you can experiment
with a lot of entrepreneurial ideas
and see what sticks and what flies well
we're we're in business to make money
and but the other thing is providing
such a cash flow for you
well it all belongs to the shareholders
uh we're not
dilating no i know we are business
people and
it is true that if you find an idea
that requires three or four years of
improvement
and patience and really sticking with it
that we're very good at that
take windows which we bet our company on
everybody
doubted that would succeed ibm did not
support us in that
it took longer than we expected over
four years before finally graphical
interface got popular
and now people take it for granted it's
part of every personal computer and you
just
you just expect it to be there that was
one of the grand successes of the
company
in the same way we're betting on the
internet that our tools there will be
popular
and that a few of these content plays
that we've decided to get involved in
that the scale and and the users will
make those into
great businesses we also are big
believers in in united way and
and what goes on there and that's more
at a business level we sort of think
every business
ought to do that it's a basic thing
because social services
uh we think have a a particular priority
in terms of drawing employees in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons
and great stories get the word out make
it fun make it easy
you know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then we
send you no more email
uh so we've made it the easiest thing to
do is
is is participate
in terms of individuals it's quite
different you know you can
take and give to groups like united way
who are really thinking about everything
in the community or you can find things
and
most people mix this you can find things
that you're particularly interested in
that you know about that a relative
benefited from or that you want to go
and volunteer
in uh you know microsoft does the thing
now for every hour
that somebody volunteers we actually uh
make a grant to that organization
because
that says that there they care about it
and they think it's
it's doing very good work now for
individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be in the community where you know
what's going on
i'm a big believer that that the some of
the greatest inequities are on a global
basis
and so one of the things our foundation
tries to get out is the names of a
number of organizations like
save the children or global fund or
vaccine fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way
and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people are able to be fairly
generous that this international
component that it be part
of of what they're doing obviously if
you get up to enough scale then you can
uh take on big projects and i will get a
chance
with some of my extra time to go out and
and share with people who are
uh lucky enough to have wealth and
just tell them how much fun i'm having
and that can have impact and
hopefully encourage it i i think when
warren buffett gave his gift it
sent a message to people that wow uh
we got this is the the right thing to do
and you know he he doesn't
like to waste money uh so you know a
sense that there are
causes out there that you can make a big
difference with
there's no doubt that
uh you know creating a board having
people like dave marquart there
who wasn't at the company you know and
we were
so overwrought about you know this is
right this is wrong we messed this up
that having people have a little bit of
distance uh
come in and talk to us is good you know
for the last
uh oh 30 years or so
i've gotten to be friends with warren
buffett and he
he's in omaha uh he's not in this tech
world at all you know and to him it's
like
hey how could you ever know which will
rise and which will fall i'm not going
to put money
until apple sold at a multiple of 12.
then
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
[Laughter]
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had an
uh iphone that was half as expensive
would you switch away
you know or is it more like jewelry
where you really want
to to have an iphone and so he decided
that the
those profit streams might not be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not
in this world he has a
a definite way of looking at things
including this idea of how
uh work should be fun he has made his
work so much fun
that he works more hours than i do
he works six days a week at 88 years old
and he likes to say that he skips to
work every day he
he doesn't but he says that
when he was 83 he could still skip but
now he's done
really he can't do it so
uh having somebody like that
you know the toughest thing i went
through was this anti-trust lawsuit
where you know it didn't seem uh very
predictable uh
and he was a great council during all of
that stuff so getting somebody who's in
successful in another domain uh
but yet kind of a business uh type
mindset anyway for me that that was a
huge gift
i think it's important that we build
that feedback system
now exactly how you do that how much you
connect that up
to the pay system uh you know we need
experimentation
and we can look at these other countries
that have done it there is a move afoot
to do some of this but whether the
investment levels be enough to make it
high quality
and whether the there'll be kind of high
stakes that overuse the test scores
for this stuff and and will sort of hurt
its reputation
it's hard to say at this point but i'd
say it's uh giving more feedback to
teachers
would be the very first thing that would
get us
back up to the uh to be one of the best
in the world
if you want to have impact uh usually
delegation's important
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started
i wrote most the code and everybody
else's code i read and kind of rewrote
uh and that got us up to 10 people
and then i had to say to myself okay
we're going to ship code that i
didn't edit uh and that was hard for me
uh but you know i kind of got over that
then i still said okay i'm going to
interview everyone
and i'm going to at least look at
samples of their code well that got us
up to about 40 people
and that was at a point where i had sold
way more software than we could write
because everybody was so impressed and i
thought
well i need to keep enough collect
enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but
uh the demand was so high that you know
we were actually
falling behind that's when i hired steve
and steve
figured out a uh how to control
what promises i made to people uh and b
how to hire lots of people
and good really good people and create
organizations and teams so i delegated
to steve that
and he was constantly saying to me okay
we're gonna hire programmers that you've
never met and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work
uh you know so uh then i said okay
then i would you know know all the
managers of the people and so over time
uh and of course you know i could say
the quality per person was falling
monotonically uh
uh according to me uh
but you know large problems uh
if you want to you know write the most
popular office productivity software
that one person absolutely can't do that
you can write pretty code so
everyone has to decide what scale of
organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader
and a reviewer of managers but the top
people and i hired some super
experienced people
i would make sure they were pursuing a
common vision and they were well
coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff
they were way better than i was now i
had to have the framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but a lot
of uh you know my
value adam was picking say to do
graphics user interface or to do an
integrated office
uh type thing or to go global and not
use agents to have microsoft be present
all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people
uh to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders
don't aren't able to scale that up and
kind of give up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from urgency
that i felt that if we didn't get
microsoft going right away that somebody
uh would do a great job building a
software company we won't have a chance
that probably
ended up not being true that i could
have waited two or three years
and the opportunity to do microsoft
still would be there but anyway i felt a
sense of urgency
uh and you know it's not like you know i
still get to take courses and learn
things um today you know things like the
learning company and there's all sorts
of great books so
it's not like i've missed some part of
my education
when you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do if
one of your children dropped out of
college to start a company what would
you say
well i'd have to say yes but uh the
dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision
uh you know if you try and start a
company it doesn't go well they always
let you go back
uh and so if you don't have
you know kids that you need to uh
support
you know it's a very low risk thing
particularly in the
culture of the united states where
trying to start something and and
failing is not a black mark for the rest
of your life
when you were starting microsoft there
were a lot of other software companies
and you were not
number one at the beginning i think
there were mothers who were a little bit
further ahead
what was it that enabled you to beat
everybody else up in the software
business was it
bill gates was it something else what
was the unique factor that made you the
most successful
yeah we were actually the first and but
there were companies uh
and they were all kind of single product
companies
who got ahead of us uh in terms of sales
um you know by uh
about 1991 we
did become the largest uh of all of them
we were an engineering company we were
about how you hire smart people and how
you use tools to develop software
broadly
we were global and we weren't about a
single product
so like for example word perfect was a
word processor
somebody might remember uh they did so
well with that product that their gross
sales
rivaled ours when we were doing a broad
set of products
as soon as graphics interface caught on
which was windows
uh that became mainstream in 1995 we
became far
larger than the other software companies
now subsequently
uh you know google apple
uh amazon have become uh
you know also extremely successful but
in the 90s
we were the strongest uh
okay by far there's no doubt that the
anti-trust lawsuit was bad for microsoft
and if we would have been more focused
on
creating the uh phone operating system
and so instead of using
android today you would be using windows
mobile if it hadn't been for the honor
trust case
uh microsoft would go oh we were so
close we we you know
i was just too distracted i screwed that
up
because of the distraction and you know
we were just three months too late with
the release that motorola would have
used on a phone
uh so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that is for sure
that you know now nobody here has ever
heard of windows mobile
but oh well and i wouldn't uh
well that's a few hundred billion here
and there uh
i wouldn't have retired as soon and that
one is less
you know i am disappointed that windows
mobile didn't succeed but in terms of
uh my own life you know even though it
was a very painful thing
because i got very personally involved
in the defense of the company
the fact that i retired earlier probably
net was good for me because i got
down the learning curve on the
foundation i got to partner with melinda
in the early days of the foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain
uh because basically you know only 99
of things have worked out very very well
the
idea that you could get people to to
decide
to support this foreign aid thing which
is a big deal
uh for our foundation from a numeric
point of view we're still
pushing that a little bit but honestly
the story of the one
child you know if you say to an audience
here's the picture of the child shall we
save this child
they're more engaged than if you said
hey let's save a million children
you know so there's definitely a sort of
you know 10 to the sixth
problem uh here somewhere
humans are not wired uh
to be to do that on a numeric basis
um and so you know that's why we have
people like bono
and and many others who come from a more
storytelling
world and then they let me throw a few
charts and numbers then
because i think uh that that should
should be there once your heart tells
you what direction to go in
to prove that this is a a very
affordable
not you know not a big deal well managed
path to
to be on if you were 20 years old today
and you wanted to start a new company
drop out of harvard what
company or what area would you want to
start it in well this is a
great time to be doing innovation
because the tools of innovation are so
much better
there are lots of things in biology that
are very interesting
uh there are lots of things in energy
that are interesting given my
background i would start an ai company
that
whose goal would be to
teach computers how to read so that they
can absorb and understand
all the written knowledge of the world
that's an area where ai
has yet to make progress and it will be
quite profound when we achieve that goal
most people over the last 200 years or
so whoever the
the wealthiest person in the world was
didn't usually work that hard when they
got to be
60 or so they kind of took life easy you
seem to be working pretty hard what
motivates you to still work so hard well
i love
my work the work of the foundation is
super interesting i get to meet with the
scientists i get to go out
in the field i do think your habits are
sort of set
in your 20s and 30s and
by my standards of the 20s well you know
i didn't believe in weekends back then
uh not to mention vacations so i'm you
know fairly
lazy compared to myself in my 20s where
i was a true
uh fanatic uh you know all i believed in
was working on software
night and day and and for my twenties
that was perfect i didn't have
a wife or family uh at all
and my rule was very hands-on role
you know i i'm very lucky that my
foundation work
the part-time work i do for microsoft i
see that extending
you know for decades into the future and
having an understanding of innovation uh
you know i think shaping innovation in
many of these areas
uh there is a unique role that i can i
can help play
i like to look at numbers a lot and so
when i look at the numbers i'm just
amazed whether it's
the quality of the inner city education
the dropout rates
oprah did a thing where she had kids
from an inner city school go look at the
suburban school and vice versa and they
were just stunned that the building and
everything
was so completely different so i think
you know even for me i have to go you
know whether it's the
inner city in america talking to people
who live there
or outside the us we have this same
thing you know
the situation in africa you know it's
overwhelmingly
uh black population is so much worse
than people are probably aware of and so
hands-on visits
whether it's to the schools or the
clinics i think that
is necessary to hear the voices of
people who've been hurt
and then you know there's a lot of good
movies now there's a lot of good books i
was just reading the new jim crow which
is pretty
eloquent and forceful about the justice
system and the role that it plays in
perpetuating
bad conditions and you know it takes a
lot to try and put yourself
having empathy for other people so we
all have to push harder on this
i get to when i you know say okay we're
going to build a
tb drug team we're going to build the tb
vaccine team we're going to build them
uh
you know kill all the mosquitoes in the
world gene drive
crisper team i get to
in terms of how we fund that organize it
how many locations
do we wait till they have this result
before we scale it up
i get to use the same uh
or 80 percent the same uh type of
thinking that i exercised in terms of
okay let's go do windows let's go do
excel
so it's backing engineers it's getting a
sense of the team
you know what needs to be added to that
team or the iqs on the team
adding up uh as opposed to subtracting
from each other
and it's very comfortable because the
the most intense period
of microsoft was where these teams were
about size 30
and for our diseases you know typhoid
rotavirus there's a lot of diseases uh
that hopefully you'll never hear of
again uh most of which don't exist here
in the us
but uh so it is very very similar
it takes a decade generally from start
to finish the aids vaccine actually run
year 14
and it'll probably be another eight to
ten years before
that one is completely done so some take
as long as as
20 years because there's many dead ends
and you have
kind of a portfolio of approaches but
yes i feel like
my working with governments hiring smart
people
managing teams it did prepare me well
for this very
operational organization
that's a lot like a business except that
we're our profit is live
saved as opposed to a monetary
measure certainly during the time i was
at harvard i wasn't sure what i was
going to do
uh the idea that software was this field
that
uh was the opportunity was
unbelievable that became more obvious
during the three-year period i was here
but my dad had been a lawyer i thought
of mathematics
you know like doing well in the putnam
that was the coolest thing uh
and the computer software i didn't think
those
people were as smart as the math people
so it's like well am i going to go into
the easy field
uh or this really hard field but uh
anyway math uh was fantastic when i
finally picked
and decided to go go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age uh 19 uh
to about 40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or
how mitochondria work i was pretty
monomaniacal
and when i was able to ask steve this is
the year 2000 c balmer
uh he he mistakenly graduated
uh but then he started it stand
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine
but then he started at stanford business
school
and he was in his first year and i
thought this is perfect i'll get him to
drop out of
stanford business school uh so in a
certain sense he is a dropout
uh uh and he was very key to the success
of microsoft i mean
uh he knew a lot of things but during
that period i didn't get to do much
at harvard you know i took all these
courses because
it was just so amazing that people were
interested in talking about them
and uh i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed
up for i finally started to work on
those uh so i was in hillel
the minute would open to the minute it
would close during reading period trying
to catch up on
on that other set of courses so people
say i'm a dropout which is
literally true but
because i like college courses the
online
college courses there's a company called
the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
you know at least four or five
courses a year in a sense i like
uh going to college more than anyone uh
so i've sort of made sure my job
certainly post microsoft uh that i get
to spend my time meeting with scientists
learning new things you know seeing what
the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on
uh those very very hard problems i
decided to
to focus more on uh giving away than
than making money and so i've
uh gotten a chance to travel the world
be out in africa and asia quite a bit
and see the needs that are out there
and now our foundation is very focused
on global health
uh focused on agriculture because the
majority of the
the very poor in the world are farmers
who have very small plots of land so any
increase in productivity or
certainty of their crop coming in can
make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to uh people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now
it's about vaccines now a lot it's it's
with various
uh governments uh the donor governments
the governments and
import countries but at its core it's
really
basically the same thing which is uh
finding innovators people who've got
breakthrough ideas
be willing to back them understand what
they're working on
measure what they're coming up with try
and make sure that when it's delivered
it really has the impact it's supposed
to be in getting into a feedback loop
driven by
a very precise measurement first i met
warren
we were talking about getting together
and doing uh something again
he pulled out his calendar and the pages
were
so blank and i said wow
you know you've managed to avoid getting
tied into a lot of kind of meaningless
activity
and you know warren said yeah you have
to be good at saying no
and picking the things that that really
make a difference and that's one of many
things i've learned from warren but
that's one of my favorites and uh
so i can blame it on him whenever i'm
turning things down
the nice thing now that i'm not
so extreme in my 20s i i didn't get to
read
uh much at all and so like all this
stuff is going on in biology and math
um i just didn't didn't get to read it
then when i did get into my 30s
those vacations were a time to
go back uh because when i was a student
you know you could study all sorts of
things uh
anyway um now
you know i read a lot of science uh and
that
uses up uh you know maybe half of the
slots
uh that that i have
really understanding u.s poverty and
what's going on there there's a
few dozen books that try and give you a
glimpse of that that are very good
this book fact on this let me say you
know it definitely
uh creates a framing
uh for what's going on in the world and
the other one that's right up there is
any
pinker book starting with uh
better angels of our nature i think
success is always a bit dangerous
you know and you can think that whatever
your success was
was because you know you are magically
uh gifted in understanding things
whereas of course
any success particularly a gigantic
success
is a huge number of factors including
hard work and understanding but
timing you know other people who came to
work with you other people who might
have done the same thing who somehow
messed up uh in doing it and so often
you'll
you'll have too much confidence about
what you
understand uh you know in science
uh as feynman said the easiest person to
fool is yourself
and so you have to force yourself to go
through uh
you know again and again and think
through is this the right thing to be
doing
you know will this work am i doing it
because it would be exciting if it
succeeded am i
really looking at these factors in fact
in polio several times we had to say to
ourselves
was it time to give up or really
did we think there was a prospect of
being able to move forward
you have any regrets in your life you
seem to have a life that many people
would love to live you got a happy
family
great marriage foundation business
success is there anything can you make
us feel good by saying
you've done something that didn't work
out or just make us
because all of us feel bad because we
look at you and we can't do what you've
done so
tell us something that's bad that you've
done or you'd feel inadequate about
something it must be something i am
super lucky uh
you know they marrying melinda
uh the experience at microsoft uh that
although it had
its ups and downs was uh phenomenal
uh the work of the foundation and
no regrets about anything i wouldn't try
and go back and change anything
i mean for example the antitrust lawsuit
against microsoft
you know was bad for the company it
created a lot of distraction we would
have done a lot of things including the
mobile operating system better
if it hadn't been for that but in a way
it was a lesson for me
uh and you know so it
and it probably accelerated my
retirement
uh by five or six years which overall
for me probably was a a good thing um
you know i don't think it was a
principled set of activities but that's
another story
so today the greatest pleasure of your
life is when you're doing what
is it other than being interviewed by me
or something like that what are the
great
greatest pleasure of your life uh you
know
time with kids time with scientists
uh time when i'm reading and things are
making sense
um you know going out and seeing the
impact of the foundation's work
uh meeting with scientists who think we
can
make breakthroughs to help solve climate
uh you know these are super interesting
problems and you know having a broad set
of system thinking
applied to these problems is going to be
necessary
uh to orchestrate the resources and
policies behind them so
you know i love i love my work the key
thing
was that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was uh 13 in eighth grade
when this time sharing terminal came in
and we just
did it day and night and you know got
better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law
exponential improvement that that was a
magic combination and we we'd look
around and say hey how come everybody's
not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
going to dethrone ibm
and uh you know why doesn't digital
equipment get it why is the guy who runs
it this is a company that's long gone
uh but dominated many computers at the
time why isn't that guy up there saying
it's it's wrong we know it's right
and so the key event for us was it was a
very cold
boston winter and a kid computer
came out on uh this popular electronics
magazine
and we said oh damn this is happening
without us
i mean here we are uh doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready
uh and then we called them back we
actually did the work and then we called
them back and said
how do you make the stuff go in and out
of the computer
the i o and they said well that's
interesting nobody else has ever asked
that you must really be doing something
so that was anyway our very first
customer
and so we grabbed on to it to be the
very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry and come
and do it
in a sense it was one of the lower risk
things i've ever done in my life because
you know i could have always gone back
uh you know what
my parents my dad didn't say hey if you
go away for a few years i'll stop paying
for your education they were nice and
said okay go
you know learn your lesson down there in
the desert and uh
then you get back to the serious stuff
and you know we're still
we're still waiting if you want to learn
computer science just
you know knuth wrote the book buy it
okay
uh you know read it and do the problems
for if you really
think you know this thing if you want to
learn physics feynman wrote the book
uh just read the damn book it's all
there
so that when we put stuff online it
we don't have anything in online physics
that's any better than feynman's book
honest honestly now it's a little easier
to learn
uh you know the guy makes jokes every 20
minutes or at least tries to
uh and he does more demos and things so
learning is a weird social phenomena
and so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the group that does the worst with
online learning are low-income
students because their notion of why am
i
learning their sense of self-confidence
the ability to figure out oh i just got
stuck
because you know two minuses cancel out
and i i never
saw that notation before they just hit
dead ends
all the time that if you're sitting in
your dorm at stanford
you know somebody walks down and uh
helps you get through it
i feel like you always seem to swing for
the fences in general it's just sort of
a new way of framing it
but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss well hopefully uh you
get more than one swing
yeah either at the same problem like you
know multiple malaria vaccine constructs
so that you know if you have two or
three
the combined chance of success is much
higher or that you're working in
multiple areas
not just one area right you know in
climate for example
i have a company that's uh trying to
make a nuclear reactor
that would be very cheap and that would
have safety so that
the public would be very accepting of it
now you know even i realize that's
high risk you know less than 50 percent
chance all that comes together and yet
uh if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate
uh let us generate electricity without
any greenhouse gases
when i started microsoft i didn't think
of it as all that risky i mean i was so
excited about what we were doing
it's true i could have gone bankrupt uh
but
you know i had a set of skills that were
highly employable
and in fact my parents were still
willing to let me go back to harvard and
finish my
education if i wanted to you've always
got a job with maybelline
and the only the thing that was scary to
me wasn't quitting
and starting the company it was when i
started hiring my friends
and they expected to be paid
and and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that i'd counted on
to come through and so then i got this
incredibly conservative approach that i
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay
a year's worth of payroll uh even if we
didn't get any
any payments coming in and i'm almost
true to that the whole time we have
about 10 billion now which is is pretty
much enough for the next year
anyway you know i if you're going to
start a company it takes so much
energy that you know you it better
overcome your
your feeling of risk i don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career i think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go
lease premises they they made that hard
for me you couldn't rent a car uh when
you were
under 25 at the time so i was always
taking taxis to go see customers
and the people with you know people say
we're going to go have a discussion in
the bar well i couldn't go to the bar
[Applause]
and but you know that's fun because i'll
tell you
when people are first skeptical and they
go this kid doesn't know anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa
you know they know a lot uh let's really
do
an incredible amount with these people
so our youth at least in this country
uh was a huge asset for us once we
reached
a certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old
older people um because they'll be a
little bit conservative about
whether they should come in and take the
risk and
it took three or four years before we
could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come with starting the
firm you better
think of those as as part of the the
pleasure part of the
the challenge that that is part of the
the excitement
throughout our history we wake every day
knowing
that in the business of technology
you have to think about what are you
missing what is the research or customer
feedback
that you should be paying more attention
to and how do you keep that pace of
innovation
very very high how do you make sure
you're hiring the very best people
and that kind of focus is has helped
drive us forward through all the
milestones the company has had
certainly the internet is is a great
example of that we had to
tear up our our plans and and step back
and say
well how do we how do we really embrace
all that's good about the internet and
recognize some of the shortcomings and
make sure we're leading the way
in reducing what what has held people
away from the internet
computers when i was young were super
expensive
and my friend paul allen and i actually
snuck into
places at the university of washington
where they had computers that weren't
being used at night
and so we were fascinated by what the
computer could do
but very few people were getting
exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer onto a chip
that intel would make and that would
make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using
so both more powerful and available to
people on a personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work
we were super lucky to
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think
did they say there's something wrong
with this young man he wants to just do
computers
they knew i was obsessed with computers
that i would
skip athletics that i'd go in overnight
that i'd
you know leave the house sometimes when
they prefer i went
go work at night on these things and so
it was kind of considered a little
strange
and the big moment was when i said
instead of going to part of my senior
year
that i wanted to go work for company
writing software
so they were great about allowing that
to be my hobby
you went to harvard and you dropped out
have you ever thought how your life
could be better off if you had gotten
your harvard degree
well i i'm a weird dropout because i
take college courses all the time
i love uh learning company courses and
and things so i love being a student and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you
and they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart
uh so i i feel it was unfortunate
uh that i didn't get to stay there but i
don't think i missed
any knowledge because you know whatever
i needed to learn i would
i was still in a a learning mode so you
are here with your daughter who is
21 right and you were 21 when you became
a billionaire
is that right almost yeah all right so
around that age you were you were like
the youngest person to become
a billionaire is that right for you yeah
in terms of my own
earning it on my own yeah right okay so
which is the most important thing yeah
so did you when you were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's
it just happened uh mostly i love
software
uh i do remember the private school i
went to there were other kids whose
families were better off
like they had a porsche or something but
it wasn't that that big of a deal
my thing was that i just loved doing
software i loved hiring people
and i was stunned when it ended up being
so valuable
really yeah that surprised you yeah
because i always had to be careful that
we wouldn't hire too many people i was
always worried because i was
people who worked for me were older than
me and they had kids and i always
thought what if we don't get paid
will i be able to meet the payroll so i
was always very conservative
about the finances and then when we did
go
uh public uh was i uh
30 by then uh then i was kind of stunned
at what it
multiplied out to education is
essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they
have available uh you know i took
these numbers won't make any sense
anymore but the hardest freshman math
class was called math 55
uh i assume it's not called that anymore
but it was it was a group of
uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math
that they had ever met so there were 79
frauds
uh one person who really was the
the best at math i ended up the guy who
came in first in the class is a lawyer
in new york
now uh the guy who came in second as a
professor of chaos theory of
princeton uh and then i came in third
so i knew okay math geez that's
interesting anyway
uh i didn't take physics uh
55 but i read the feynman book
and so if you're motivated seriously you
don't have to take a course the feynman
book
if you're hardcore just read the finding
book do the problems
you want to learn to do software read
the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but uh you know anyone that's rated 30
or harder
is like super hard to do and so
a mooc in a sense doesn't change what
counts uh you know it's always been in
the textbook
but the percentage of students who just
buy textbooks and
and read them and know the subject is
vanishingly small
you kind of have to have this thing
where a bunch of kids all come at the
same time
uh and you know if you don't study
you're going to get a bad grade and your
parents may not like that
you have to create all these social
things in order for people to get into
this mode of
hyper concentrating and actually
understanding
why should i concentrate you know if i'm
a high school student they put x's and
y's up on the board
how does that relate to my life now if
you understood that being good at math
lets you get a good job
travel the world you might say okay it
does relate to me but that's a very
indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that uh to concentrate
that's what's missing and so moocs
to the degree that it's easier to take a
mooc than it is to read a textbook yeah
that's nice it's a little bit
interactive there's a video
that's probably why i like the learning
company like all their economics there's
a guy named timothy taylor who has
five courses on economics i super
recommend uh
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
engage in that learning and how do you
create the environment
and the sense of achievement and the
sense of capability
that sitting in there and you know
looking at x's and y's and manipulating
them
uh seems like a smart thing to do let's
say you're interviewing for
a junior engineer position at microsoft
sitting in a boardroom or
on video call in 2020 why should we hire
you
you should look at the code that i've
written you know i'm kind of crazy i
write software programs way beyond any
classes that i've taken and think i've
gotten better over time so take a look
at
how ambitious i've been there i do think
i can work well
with people i might criticize their code
a little harshly but overall
i like to be on a team i like ambitious
goals
i like thinking through how we can
anticipate the future
software is cool and i want to be
involved how would you define
your strengths and your weaknesses how
you can you know incorporate those into
a team kind of aspect
well i'm not somebody who knows a lot
about marketing
you know i wouldn't enjoy being a
salesman for a position where you're
actually
creating the products and thinking
through what those features should be
i'm fascinated by that i've followed the
history
of the industry read about the mistakes
that have been made
so product definition product creation
very strong
if you have a team that understands the
customers the sales the marketing i'm
not going to bring that but i
i would enjoy working with them when you
have a tragedy like this pandemic
there is always the possibility you're
going to
narrow your community that you care
about
you're going to think about yourself
your family not the whole
country including those who've been been
somewhat left behind
likewise there's a risk looking at
africa and other developing countries
and saying no we need to help them out
because
difficulties there of not enough food
are really extreme and
small amounts of the budget less than
one percent can help them out
likewise you don't want to just think
about the here and now you also want to
think about the future after all
the government failed us by not
anticipating this pandemic
there were voices like mine in ted talk
and other venues that
kind of said hey get ready we don't know
when but it's coming
sadly that didn't happen another thing
we trust government to get us ready for
is climate change that's coming and it
won't be as easy as
creating a vaccine to solve it and so
right now
terms of people's sympathy being broad
you know being willing to address other
problems even though they're not
here right now i am actually seeing a
lot of positive voices people saying
make sure the recovery is a green
recovery europe
has done a lot on that and so and
actually the dialogue
in politics about you know does climate
change matter
is stronger today than it's ever been so
this closing in
and only worrying about the short term
i'm not seeing that
of course your audience which is very
young will be the key
to saying let's not just
look at this short term let's start the
investments
that deal with inequities let's start
the investments that can make sure
climate change doesn't come in and and
have even more tragic results than this
pandemic does
young people thinking about policies
getting involved
i think i'm seeing an uptick i hope
that's sustained because they're you
know they're the ones who will
really do the innovative work we think
that progress can actually accelerate
the last
last 15 years have been wonderful but
the next 15
uh we can do more uh and
some people worry that when you you talk
about progress that it'll
reduce people's commitment to make
things better
they think when you talk about progress
that it shows you're naive and that
maybe you don't realize
uh all those things that are left to be
done and how
horrific they are and you know so
sometimes that
purely that negative side of the story
gets told but
you lose something very important uh if
you only look at it that way
uh you lose the optimism about what's
possible and you lose the information
where you look at the places that have
done better than others and you
understand
what is it about delivery innovation
partnerships caring what has come
together uh
for the very best progress and then
spread that
to the other places that's what will
help us drive
at full speed historically the
newspapers or the
the media were very responsible about
not
letting uh untruths about vaccine safety
get out there
now you know you don't want to get rid
of the good thing which is that anybody
can publish
that barriers to entry the diversity of
voices
is so phenomenal compared to to
traditional publishing
right i feel like and you have a bit of
youtube presence so you're able to share
information about things uh through
social media it's kind of a social media
age so i feel like that
ideally helps your cause more than it
hurts it yeah my audience
probably isn't uh deep with the vaccine
doubters
uh yeah you know i in a creative way
uh trying to get positive messages to uh
be interesting and we have work to do on
that you know i would have thought
using experts on scientific knowledge
that the
all the internet would just make it so
much easier to learn about things
and yet in some ways you know people
aren't seeking out
complex information particularly if it
disagrees
uh with some preconceived notion that
they have so
you know how can social media
get out there and be a little bit of a
uh
force for education particularly on
climate where
without a consensus we won't do the
hard things that will save things for
the next generation
part of the thing that drives computer
science forward is
is doing risky things having a long term
time horizon
and microsoft was a small company we
benefited from the fact that
a t and xerox and other companies had
made
investments in research that they'd
reached out and worked
with universities on a broad basis so we
felt very lucky that as we got
to a certain level of success we could
start our own research group
and have that research group be in
partnership with top universities all
over the world doing
advanced programming programs things
that range from
the work on speech recognition all the
way up to quantum computing
we have a fairly serious program that
has a you know high risk of failure
which makes it fun and interesting on
quantum computing and you know even in
the best case it's probably
a decade away before that makes a
difference but that's the kind of thing
that when it works can have incredibly
high payoff we felt a little bad
i i certainly i did about leaving the
university
when uh i thought very interesting work
on artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now
you know it's taken a long time the rate
of progress which is hard to make
numeric
in both those areas has been quite
modest i mean we haven't gone backwards
or anything but
a.i has turned out to be a tougher
problem which is
is fascinating and now there there are
some interesting
advances and likewise symbolic type
things
there are some now advances so we
thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research
we get to have some level of involvement
in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice
uh architecture to just you know blow
away the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring
compared to personal computing a company
came along about five years later two
pie
and did it they didn't do the software
piece right that's why they failed
because we still think it was a good
idea but we didn't have anything even
close to
hey let's build the computer that we
want to use that we want to have as a
tool for our own
uh messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from the
special bonus clips that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the billionaire mindset question of
the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar get ready for another amazing
video tomorrow or if you don't have it
yet you can get it for free in the first
line of the description below and if
you're enjoying this billionaire mindset
series give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
i think that this is a deep problem in
perception
is that if you want something to improve
you have a tendency to be bothered by
the status quo
and to think that it's much worse than
it is and that can be beneficial because
you
you don't like say the level of violence
in the world the level of poverty the
level of number of kids dying
but if you divorce yourself from the
true facts of improvement and
and look at the exemplars looked at
what's worked if you get
sort of a general despair about is the
world improving
then you won't latch on to those
examples
uh the the the stephen pinker example
one of my favorite books of all time is
if you ask people
is this one of the most violent errors
in history
they will say yeah so overwhelming
americans say yes
well it's it's overwhelmingly the least
violent era in history
and so what it means is your disgust at
violence actually
increases and that's partly why
uh we take steps and why uh within our
own society in the world but large it's
come down
so dramatically if you want to sign up
for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there